- Hi everyone.
Good afternoon, welcome.
And it is my absolute
pleasure to invite you all
to the post-doc discussion
session that we have
for our monthly Colloquium
Series on the Inference project.
So as you all know yesterday
we had a wonderful talk by
professor Jim Weatherall,
of University of California, Irvine
and the title of his talk was,
"Why do Groups Polarize
over Matters of Fact?
What Models Can and Cannot Tell Us?"
So, we started with, he
started with telling us
about these four different approaches
and he outlined the
limits and the advantages
of each of these modeling approaches
to look at highly
polarized groups of people.
And this kind of agent modeling,
it give us a sort of an introduction
to some of these agent
modeling techniques,
which scholars in the social
sciences have often used
in lieu of the kinds of
simulations that physicists,
astronomers and people in
climate modeling and other fields
use sort of simple sort
of numerical models.
So it's a new kinds of simulations
that help us examine social behavior.
So, today it is my pleasure to introduce
our discussant professor, Kevin Dorst,
who is on the faculty at
the department of philosophy
at the University of Pittsburgh,
where he is an assistant professor.
And he received his PhD from MIT,
spent a year as a Junior Research Fellow
at Magdalen College in Oxford
before starting this position.
And all of his research
projects have centered
around one kind of meta big question
which is "What Should We
Think About How People Think?
And typically psychology is a discipline
that is used to answer this question.
And psychology informs us
that people's thinking that
we are actually very irrational as people,
unlike the premise in often
a lot of economic modeling
where we are supposed to
make rational choices.
But his work has shown
that these sort of
irrationalist interpretations
of data are actually questionable
and they rely on very simple models
of what rational people would think
and also these two
contrasts of modeling people
as either rational or irrational.
And his work has tried to
bring much more philosophically
sophisticated models of rationality,
to bear on the
interpretation of these types
of empirical results reclaimed
in order to help assess
the degree of irrationality
and how, assess how
irrational we really are.
And so this is sort of
his big picture view
and it's connection to
polarization in politics
is something that he
explores in his blog post,
"A Plea for Political Empathy."
So I urge you all to go
and take a look at it.
And for an extended
argument that polarization
has its roots in rational causes,
see the series, "Reasonably Polarized:
why politics is more
rational than you think."
So I urge you to go take
a look at his blog feed
which is really really exciting.
And before we embark on
today's discussion session
I just wanted to remind you about
some of our ongoing projects
for which we would love your input.
And one of them is our
learning by doing projects
these simple experiments that
can be conducted by kids,
supervised with parents
or teachers at home.
So, please consider either adding
to our roster of experiments
or sending us videos
of your kids performing these experiments.
That's saying that our speaker
in the Inference series
for June will be Eric Winsberg
and before for the redo
I also want to thank
our benefactors, Barbara
and Richard Franke
for their support of the Franke Program
as well as many other activities at Yale.
So Kevin, take it away please.
- Thanks so much for having
me in the introduction.
I was telling Jim before the talk
this is like ideal timing for me to
work on some of these
computational models too
and have a lot of big picture questions
about what we're doing
when we're over doing them.
So I was thinking this was the opportunity
at least for me to reel and
learn from Jim a little bit
someone who's been doing
as much longer than I have
and hopefully it'll be fruitful.
I also realized, well
Priya was giving that
very nice introduction
that I found my first type
one the handout which is
and I forgot to change
the title of this handout.
And so you might have
with that introduction
and with the title you might think
I'm gonna be going on
and on about rationality.
And actually that wasn't
my plan or in talking
about a little bit, but
maybe they'll come back.
But I knew myself, well I was thinking
I would do just in like
the opening comments
questions just to
refresh everyone's memory
on the three models that Jim
talked us through last time,
trust, conformity and reporting practices
and the big picture upshot,
he was sketching from them.
And then use that sort of
upshot and sort of some
of its pessimism that
I think he rightfully
introduced at the end
as like a launching off
point for like, well to ask
the question what really we can
and should be trying
to do when we're using
these sort of simple computational models,
to try to understand complex sometimes
attractable social phenomenon.
So I'm gonna the handout I
think is shared in the chat
but I'm also gonna share my screen just
for people who don't have
it or can't download it
or to walk through the handout together.
Nothing too surprising
here, but just as a anchor
for where you are, can everyone see that?
Sharing screen up so?
- [Priya] Yeah, thanks.
- Excellent.
So starting with a sort of summary of what
we talked about yesterday so,
Jim introduced three different models
that lead to polarization
from some possible
of cause is the first is trust dynamics.
So, we have a bunch of little agents
a network that have some lines
of communication between each other.
They have to decide which
of two options to perform
option B or option A.
Option A they know it's expected value.
Option B they're unsure of
how good an option A is.
The standard example is,
which treatments I prescribed
to my patients doctors might wonder.
And if you're interested
in some, examples of this
Jim and Cailin in their book,
and I think also in the paper
this is based on detailed
case study of this.
What's called the Lyme wars,
the debate over whether
chronic Lyme disease is
basically it's a thing,
whether chronic Lyme
disease, whether Lyme disease
can that has been treated with antibiotics
can sometimes linger and
therefore get further benefits
from further antibiotic treatment
is a interesting polarized, scientific
arguably scientific community
polarize on that question.
And so in that case you might think,
well some doctors are
deciding whether to describe
do I prescribe antibiotics
or something else
for this patient who may or
may not have chronic Lyme.
And so that's the sort of cases I think
where this model is most at home.
And the way this works is that
they learn both from doing
their own tests or actions.
They just, they take some options A or B
and just learn how good they are
in trying to learn whether it be as better
but they also learn from their neighbors.
Their neighbors share information
about how their own tests went.
And the key twist is
that how much they trust
their neighbors depends on
how close their neighbors
opinions are to their own.
In particular, how confident
in their neighbors are
that option B is better
than option A is a proxy
for how much they trust them.
And if they trust them
less, they'll update less
or basically treat their
information as less reliable
than if they trust them more
if their credences are closer.
And the upshot is basically that
when trust diminishes rapidly enough,
based on how far peoples far
apart people's opinions are
we often get polarization.
One group ends up pretty
confident that A is better.
They stop trusting the
people who are using B
and they're since they're doing A,
they don't learn anything
else about how good B is.
While another group ends
up certain that B is better
or arbitrarily confident that B is better
because they keep on doing B
and keep on eventually getting
evidence that it's better.
So that was the first trust dynamic model.
And so we ended up with a polarized group
because basically the sides don't listen
to each other anymore.
The second model was a
conformity based model.
So again, same structure
we got agent setting
which to do A or B they're on a network.
They can learn from their neighbors
that they share a link
with on that network.
But now, instead of having variable trust
based on the degrees of confidence,
agents feel some pressure.
You might think of this as
a social pressure to conform
to their neighbors the people
that they share links with,
the people they get information
from and can talk to
or maybe trust if any how
we interpret those links.
Those are the people that
think it's some extra utility
or value from doing what
those people are doing.
If everyone in my social circle
is a Lyme literate doctor
as they say, and prescribes antibiotics
and response to symptoms
of apparent chronic Lyme
then I feel pressure to do so myself.
Some and so I might be
inclined to do so even
if I don't believe that
chronic Lyme is susceptible
to antibiotic treatment.
And there was the basic
result here is that often
this doesn't lead to polarization
but when the network has
a particular structure
in particular what has a click structure
it can lead to polarization.
So click structure is
where you have these two
or many different groups
that are all sort of
well interconnected, but
they are loosely connected
to another group sort of like that.
Hopefully you remember that
how those look and the idea is.
Well, sometimes when you
have the sort of structure
you can have a clique of
people that are all doing A.
And so they're not learning
about how good B is
and maybe there's one person on the end
who says all these people are doing A.
And there's one person on the A to
this is like, does B, this person learns
from seeing these people
that B is actually better.
But they don't switch their action
because they feel pressure
to conform to their group.
And because they don't switch
then these people who don't
have direct connections
with other groups, never
learned that B is better.
And so everyone still set does A.
So the idea is basically the sparse
informational connections between clicks
prevent the information suggesting
that B is better from breaking
into this certain part of the network.
So that's where we get
polarization and action
and also beliefs sometimes many
of these people will believe
that A is better, or at least they can.
The third model then no longer
had a network structure.
It was based on reporting
practices of of media outlets
and how those interact or might interact
with people's response to information
and tendency perhaps to
confirm their beliefs.
So the model in this case
we sort of model journalists
are observing the world.
They're observing earthquakes,
they're observing economic consequences
or what have you said, some regular news
that they can report on
that is in some sense
represent one numerical scale in terms
of how severe or how good or bad they are.
And they have different
reporting practices.
They have to select what to report
so they can use hyperbole,
they can make things sound
more extreme than they are.
They can use extreme
reporting which is they just
they only report on extreme events
ones very far from some
expected or neutral baseline,
or they do fair reporting
where they sort of like
both sides journalism.
Where they have whenever
they get their time
to a bit of information pointing one way,
they also give their time
to a bit of information
pointing the other.
If we take those three different types
of journalistic methods and then we add
that the agents watching
them have confirmation bias
of a particular form, then
we can get polarization.
So in particular, the model
of confirmation bias is just
that people sometimes ignore journal,
the reports of journalists
and how likely they are to
ignore report is proportional
to how surprising they find that report.
So they, at a given time they
have certain beliefs about
basically how likely the
event that the economy
is to be doing well or badly or whatever.
And how likely they are to
ignore report to scales with
how unlikely they private
thought the report would be.
And the interesting result
then is for certain types
of reporting, in particular
for what you might call
bi-modal reporting where journalists
like basically they report
two different classes
of its of information for
and against more or less.
So I think that falls from
either extreme or fair reporting
or both, and Jim can correct me on this.
It's wrong, basic idea is
certain forms of reporting
that leads to polarization
because people tend to pay
attention to the stuff that they
the cluster of information
that agreed with them.
So those are three just
to refresh your memory
on three different models of polarization.
We saw all prima facia
plausible mechanisms
that could be operative
and what's leading to
real-world polarization.
And so where Jim ended his
talk was sort of the question
what should we make of
the fact that we've got
these competing models of polarization.
And we're in is a point that
I think I agree quite a bit
with but I wanna sort of
launch off from that point.
So he says, look we shouldn't
see these models really as
in competition, but we
should see them doing
is identifying different mechanisms.
Mechanisms which on their
own may be sufficient
for polarization but
can also work together
to create polarization
in a given community.
So plausibly what's going on
is that all these mechanisms
and many more of the
sorts that other models
modelers have made are
contributing to polarization.
Once we realize that that's important
and sort of frustrating because
it means that we can't look
at the dynamics of any given model we have
even when we like quite a bit.
And read off what will happen
by changing bits of the model
and say that therefore can tell us
the interventions from there.
So that the nice example Jim gave was,
look you might think, look
at the conformity model
and think look well, the
problem with polarization
is that we don't have
enough communication.
These will add more links then
the information will spread
through the network and they
won't be polarized anymore.
Good idea if this is your model
but as soon as you add
distrust into the model like
from the first model, more
communication actually
can be lead to more polarization.
There's empirical confirmation about that.
Sometimes when you pay people to look at
just confirming new sources
they end up more confident
in their prior beliefs.
So the upshot then is that,
well look, we have these
we should very cautious
basically in inferring
either predictions or
especially policy interventions.
But the effects of those
based on any of these models
and you see them in some sense interacting
in a complicated way.
So I'm gonna use that then
that seems totally right to me.
And I wanna use it as
a launching off point
for the question like big picture
question then just sort of
what is the role then given
in light of that complexity?
What is the role of the
simple computational models
like leads of a complex social
phenomenon like polarization?
So in particular, given to
two of Jim's observations
the first is that there are of course
gonna be many sufficient
and interacting causes
for that phenomenon for polarization.
So, distrust or confirmation
bias or conformity
or other things.
And Jim mentioned this
in his talk yesterday,
in order to like sort of fully understand
the interaction effects of those
it seems like we would need
to somehow try to combine
and sort of weigh those
different factors together.
And the ones that are going
to call it grand unified model
but that's seems pretty
plausibly an intractable problem.
Or at least we don't
know how to do that well.
We know how to make simple models
and analyze their dynamics.
We don't know how to combine a bunch
of simple models to make a realistic one.
It seems pretty clear that as soon as
you get one marginally realistic,
it's either gonna be
probably both gonna be
computationally attractive.
What also just inscrutable
in the sense that
there'd be too many interacting factors
it's hard to know what's causing what
and so harder and harder to test.
So on that sort of pessimistic
reading sort of like
my question is, well
what should we be trying
to do when we make a model
like this given those facts.
And I wanna, I don't
think I have an answer.
I think I have some ideas.
I think we'll maybe
raise some possibilities
and ways in which I think they
might or might not fit with
what Jim's thinking with the
models he was talking about
or doing and see what he thinks
about those possibilities
see if he has other things in mind.
And so, first option sort
of standard modelers option
we're giving all plausible explanations
where what we're doing is basically saying
how could it be that polarization arises.
And what we wanna do
when we are constructing
these simple computational
models is delineate
the maybe plausible ways
that polarization can arise
in communities that
have various structures.
Once we do that with
enough different models
we'll have a sort of catalog.
A catalog of sort of that
allows us at least in principle
to like assess the promise or risks
of various policy interventions
so we can sort of appeal to
a bunch of different models
that say, well.
Under this model here's
what this policy would do.
what it can do and so on.
That seems good as a first
pass, but the immediate problem
and this is something I
think Jim surely agrees with
that just there's just far too many
because there's far too
many how possibly models
for how you could get
polarization just to focus
on confirmation bias.
I think there's more than
probably, I would think dozens.
I think I came up with
a list of half a dozen
more different models of confirmation bias
and how it could exactly it could work
and how it could lead to polarization
and making different predictions
about what sort of various
interventions would do.
So we need some further constraints
than just that we're gonna,
we're not gonna successfully
catalog all these things,
at least until we find some way to do
like a meta analysis of
models which I don't know,
is that it all?
What's your first question
Jim, is that a thing
I feel like anyways, I want to know that.
(laughing softly)
Okay so we are more constrained broadly
I think everyone will agree
and so then I think my the
question is everything.
What should the constraints, how should,
what constraints should we used
or which strains are useful to use.
Option two here says, well
take the whole possibly
explanations constrain them
to rational models,
which will be no surprise
given the title that I
accidentally put on this handout.
So, when one constraint
we can give is okay, like
can we show that polarization
can or will arise
under maybe even quite strong
rationality assumptions?
And that can be useful
in part, at least in part
just because many explanations
of polarization appear
that irrational, appeal to irrationalities
that we can push back
against certain explanations
show that they're not necessary.
And I do have some sympathy for that
but we probably need
more constraints as well.
That's one thought, but I'm not sure
a question for Jim, is that how Jim wants
to sort of constrain things.
It sounded from the way he was defending
some of the models that he was he was less
happy to try to defend them as rational
and the confirmation bias pretty clearly
and not a rational model.
Even the scientific polarization
the trust dynamics one is maybe
at best the first past
reasonable proximity use distance
but from your belief as a measure of trust
but surely it would be.
If you put two people in a
lab in front of slot machines
and they actually follow those dynamics
you get pretty (indistinct) results.
You would think they were
doing something silly.
The conformity model I don't...
The conformity model
might actually do better
on this front zone here.
But Jim thinks about
that but so that was one
one approach is rational,
rationality as a constraint.
Another constraint we can impose
is sort of psychological
constraints or classic constraints,
psychological constraints.
So sometimes psychologists
are pretty confident about
sort of what the specific
reasoning mechanisms are
that lead to polarization,
at least in certain cases.
So there's a good number of
fairly robust if always messy
and contested empirical findings
that say under conditions
of this form here is
probably what people do
and that leads them to
confirm their place.
So confirmation bias is
a bit of an umbrella term
that fits a bunch of features
that have this sort of structure.
Positive test strategies
they ask questions they
expect the yes answers too,
selective exposure they
look for information
they expect to be confirming.
Bias assimilation when
given mixed evidence
they interpreted a way that
fits their prior beliefs.
Diagnosticity they tend not
to care about likelihoods
In fact, if you're a busy and so I mean
that's contested by the way.
But only it's are contested by the way.
But so there are a bunch of
specific reasoning mechanisms
which people arguably do
or at least sometimes do,
and one role for a modeler then seems
like it could be to like sort of
check the experimenters
intuition that if they did this,
it would lead to population
level polarization.
Sometimes just obvious like
sort of ignoring information
that tells against your beliefs,
and listening information
that tells in favor
it's like pretty clear I
mean, we can check that
but it's pretty clear that's
going to lead to polarization.
Sometimes it's not obvious and wrong
so one of the well known
instances of confirmation bias
is positive test strategy
to people asking in fact
questions they expect the answer to be yes
to give them their preferred hypothesis.
Schemas from some of the waste
and selection tasks and so on.
It turns out that doesn't lead
to predictable polarization,
unless there's some other
error along the way.
As long as you know what
question you ask then
there's no expected polarization.
So that's something that modelers can show
and so that's one role modelers can play.
Sort of looking at the details
of psychological mechanisms
and seeing what their effects are
population-wise, population level.
So maybe that's an
interpretation of at least
what the confirmation bias
model that Jim talked about
is doing but I'm not so sure.
And maybe Jim can, can
speak to this as well.
So it seems to me that if
we're gonna do this sort
of psychologically modeling
then it really is quite
important that we do our
best to match the details
of a psychological mechanism equation
that we sort of,
we have some particular
psychological mechanisms
we look at exactly how it works and then
see whether that leads to polarization.
And I mean, I think the model
of confirmation bias that
they use which is sort
of being less likely
to update information that
you find more surprising is
maybe a good first pass but definitely
there are many more details
of the empirical story.
Like if you have a story
about how selective exposure
to new evidence works then many moderators
for Jessica Wilson has
this great dissertation
on confirmation bias
which I take every chance
to plug that I can.
And one just like simple
thing to point out
is there's insofar as there's
a drive towards confirmation,
there's also a drive towards
looking at surprising things.
And that's what confirmed in
a variety of other finding
scenarios including for example,
when people look at what
causes fake news to spread.
And if we model confirmation
bias then it's just being
less likely update any information
that you find surprising.
Then that's at least in
competition with those other
mechanisms where surprises is
actually leads people more,
lead more like people to
look at that information.
So that's just to say it does
seem like there's a role for
the computational models in
sort of lifting up computate
psychological reasoning, mechanisms.
And seeing what they do
at a population level
if we apply them but it's
less clear to me that
that's what some of these models at least
are trying to do certainly.
Well, I mean to ask about, I don't know
about the conformity models, maybe those
are closer to them I'll ask Jim
to jump in on that as well.
Okay, final concern I've gone
a little bit too long here,
but final thoughts for how we
might try to further constrain
the space of possible models
is to impose further features
on the sort of polarization where
or model we observe
empirically has a constraint
on what our models should
allow us to predict.
So one classic feature polarization is
just people who have different beliefs
sustainably so, right.
But there are many other features
of at least many instances
of real-world polarization
which we might want to
try to capture as well.
So consider a classic
example of the polarizing
empirical question whether
the capital punishment
has a direct effect on many
of the psych studies that
people find confirmation bias
use this sort of question,
probably have a distantly
strong opinion on that here.
I think arguably unless
there could be questions,
question but arguably
three features of that
strong belief you have
about whether or not
capital punishment has a deterrent effect.
First it's predictable,
not merely in the sense
that it's predictable, that
people will disagree about it.
But it's predictable which
side individuals will end up
but often they can predict it too.
Often even if you're unopinionated on
whether capital punishment
has deterrent effect
you can predict what your
future belief will be.
So just take a college
student who's deciding
between a super liberal urban college
and a conservative rural college.
They can, I mean they probably wouldn't
think very much about this,
but if they thought hard
and they thought about it
a little bit I think they
would pretty constantly predict
that if I go to this liberal school,
I can predict that I'm
going to be on this side
but the anti-capital
punishment side of the debate.
And if I go to this
conservative school, vice versa.
So that's a form of predictability
which is much stronger
than just predicting
that there will be two different factions.
It's predicting which direction
a given individual will go.
Often polarization the second
feature is often profound.
It's not merely that they're
stable opposing beliefs
but they're basically
arbitrarily confident.
I believe that's possibly true of
at least certain maybe capital punishments
invest hard enough and bear
with question that people
are a little less confident but anyway,
so surely we find others.
Here's one that I think
maybe is questionable
what I'm inclined to
think is a feature as well
is that many of these
polarizations are robust,
in the sense that people's confidence
in their opinions remains upon learning
good empirical stories about
how those opinions came about.
So probably most people in this room have
read enough op-eds and maybe psych studies
and whatever on how
confirmation bias works.
And maybe they certainly
if they came to Jim Stock
they have some idea of how these sort of
models of polarization to look vivid.
Some sense of what the
social science looks like
when it comes to explaining polarization.
And I take it, no one
has changed their belief
on whether capital
punishment is insurance.
No one would become
less confident with that
upon reading some outfit
in the New York Times
about how confirmation bias works,
or at least not
significantly less confident.
And so that's, I mean,
that's a constellation
of further features that I
think many polarizations have.
And then the question,
do we have models which
explain those features?
And here is that I'm going
to spec you a little bit
and this may be a good place for Jim to
come in as well on here as well.
But I think that the confirmation
bias model they gave has
A and B but not C.
So A, it's predictable which
direction you're going to go.
You just basically look at
where your prior beliefs are
and what media reporting practices are.
Are they time bomb or not.
It could be profound because you could
as Jim was showing it
you get more and more
confident in your beliefs,
but I don't think it's going to be robust
in the sense as soon as
you tell people that,
well what you've been doing
is just ignoring information
from the other side, if
they're minimally reasonable
they'll just immediately
knock down the confidence
of their beliefs quite a bit.
I take it that's not what we do
some debate of whether just
because we're big headed
but we can come back to that.
Conformity model I think
has see robustness in the
you know what the network structure is.
And maybe even as A as
well, it's predictable.
Like if you're in a click
that's all A doers being pretty
confident you gonna end up
in A do or at least
maybe also in a believer.
I don't think it's
profound in the sense that
the reason why we get
polarization is exactly
that there's an information dam.
There's no more information is spread,
so people just don't get
any more from their beliefs.
They just keep doing what they're doing.
I think that's right, maybe
you're wrong about that,
so Jim do correct me.
And the trust model it
seems like, well, I mean,
it might depend.
I'm not actually sure about predictable
this is the question.
If we start out at time
zero when we look at people,
decision and beliefs can we predict
who is gonna end up really
confident that'd be as better.
And who's gonna end up on the sort of,
at least with not perfect accuracy,
but some confidence not true so.
How's their families,
I don't know whether it's
predictable actually.
It's profound in one sense,
one side is arbitrarily confident
but the other thinks that A is better.
And there, I think in general
just like moderately confident
not they don't get arbitrarily
confident with that.
Okay, whether it's
robust, maybe it's subtle,
but at least if people
know that what's going on
is that everyone's sharing
information that they have.
And they're just trusting people
based on distance beliefs.
Then they would know that
people are telling the truth
and so they would then
update that information.
And so it's not clear how robust it is
to knowing what the
structure, knowing the cons.
So that's my basically not
meant as a criticism per se,
as the model I don't know if we really,
there's a question, whether
you even could have a model
that would meet all these criteria.
And I think that's a subtle
interesting question as well
but an attempt to maybe try to go
from where we were at the beginning,
which how possibly models
are too unconstrained to,
can we bring in more constraints to try to
further control the space
of where we wanna go
or where we wanna look
and whether adding these
sort of features of
polarization or rationality,
or psychological restraints
could help the choice
of which models to investigate.
So I'll stop there.
I think I threw about
1400 questions at Jim,
I apologize (indistinct)
hopefully we can get some
back and forth going about
some of these things.
- Thank you so much, Kevin.
That was really a wonderful
dissection with many
clarification's as well
as really important
questions for Jim.
So Jim, please go ahead.
- Yeah, okay thank you so much, Kevin
for putting together these thoughts.
There's yeah I mean so there's
so much to think about here.
I'm actually gonna pull the handout over
to be in front of me so that
I can keep it as a guide here.
I think there are a lot of things
that say I sort of at different levels.
So of the options that you mentioned,
I think of this as
somewhere between option one
and option three with
a further possibility
for development that you don't mention.
So there's some sense in
which what we're doing here
is how possibly monitor modeling.
Because it's is a highly idealized.
We aren't trying to capture the details
of the psychological phenomenon that we're
looking to for motivation or inspiration.
In some cases they
aren't even psychological
and the sort of folk
sense of psychological
they're more like social
psychological phenomenon.
There's seems to be
some tendency of people
to behave in certain ways.
And we don't know what the
underlying psychological
mechanisms are for that, but
it's an observed behavior.
And we can extract from that behavior,
some further information that can then be
a starting point for remodeling.
But the models themselves
are essentially how possibly.
Kevin uses an expression
how plausibly sometimes
she has a paper where
she draws a distinction between that.
There's a kind of modeling
where of what your goal is
is to show that something
that someone said
was impossible, can't happen.
So I don't know if this
example will help anyone
but there was a famous claim
in the early 20th century,
sort of late early 20th century,
that language could never evolve.
Because you can't evolve
language already having language.
And one way of responding to that was
a game theoretic and eventually,
evolutionary game theoretic analysis
of how signaling systems
can come into existence
through a kind of dynamical process.
And the claim isn't that
this is how signaling systems
actually evolved, it may have
some qualitative features
in common with how they actually evolved,
but that's not the point.
The point is someone
said this was impossible,
here's a scenario in which
you should show it is possible
that establishes that it can happen.
Now there's further question
whether it did happen.
And we're doing something
that I like to think
as a little bit more than that,
because no one is going around saying
polarization cannot occur.
I mean, it seems quite clear empirically
that it does occur.
And so it's more like
let's try to understand whether
the various kinds of hypothesized
conditions that look like
they might be relevant to depolarization,
can be seen to actually
bring about polarization
even in simple cases.
And so this is what Caitlin calls,
how plausibly modeling.
It's not just for the pure sake
of establishing possibility,
but it's a similar kind
of modeling strategy
where you aren't trying to get anything
approaching the full complexity
of the system you're looking.
So yeah, go ahead.
Yeah it would be great
if we could just go back
as long as you got.
- Yeah cool, so is the thought there like
the difference maybe
between how possibly well,
at least a rule of
thumb for the difference
between how possibly for
example positively is like,
has anyone sort of wow.
And how possible you're
just trying to come up
with a mechanism that
show that it could work.
And how plausibly it's
like people have positive
of these mechanisms, and we wanna verify
that they actually do
what people think they do.
So it's something like that
I see what you mean by
sort of like option three
is it's like psychological,
but it's not necessarily psychological
in the sense of looking at the details
of how individuals are
reasoning or replicating that.
It's rather looking at
maybe a high level social
psychological tendency
and making sure that
it really is the case that it's,
people only learn from their neighbors
or whatever people don't listen
to people that have very
different opinions to them that
you will get polarization
reserving any accurate that's the.
- Yeah that's exactly right.
So that's a sense in which
we try to make the case
and for each of those
sorts of mechanisms that we're looking at.
That we are capturing some
of the salient details
that seem to be present
in the real world cases
that we're interested in and
we're asking is that enough?
And that can sometimes
happen not at the level
let me just as you say,
not at the level of
sort of the details of actual reasoning,
but rather at the level of
what behavior seem to result
from the reasoning that does take place.
And yeah so...
I mean I think as you say
there are lots of ways
of modeling confirmation bias.
There are lots of ways
of modeling trust too.
There even lots of ways
of modeling how people
change their beliefs or opinions
in light of interaction
with their neighbors.
And I mean I tend to think that even
Bayes rule is not, I mean
no one's doing easy in calculations.
I'm curious actually I mean,
I know that different
people have different
I think some people think that they are.
But I'm inclined to think
they probably aren't
or they don't need to be at least
in order for it to be the case that
strict conditionalisation
is a good way of modeling
the kind of belief updating
in light of new evidence
that agents are doing.
And so I would think of
the other kinds of USO
the kind of conformity calculation.
We imagine our agents are performing
an expected value calculation
and then acting in a way that
they believe will maximize
their pay off in the next round.
People are actually doing that calculation
is that actually what
happens when people conform?
Probably not I mean
there's a kind of gut level
decision being made I would think
but it's also the case that
there's a trade off happening
and this captures that kind of trade-off
and you can ask well
- Some of them.
- Yeah.
- Some of the neurosis
that distinct the gut-level
was exactly where all
the biggest calculation
that's going from all the, yeah
all the expected those are like manifested
as your God is telling you.
But I think we to have to go that far to.
- Well, so yeah you don't
need anyway, I mean.
Something has to be happening on,
I look, I mean if nothing else I mean
our agents have arbitrarily precise.
We're not, I mean they're floats.
Okay, so they've got 64
acre digit precise credences
which I think is probably
not perfectly accurate
as a representation of human cognition
but I don't think that that matters
for what we're trying to do.
And I think of the other
kinds of idealizations here
as similar, right.
Trying to find something
that seems to have
the right kind of qualitative behaviors,
at the level that they would
need to in order for them to
sort of be playing the kind of social role
that is being explored in the model.
And so that's, that's it.
- Yeah and so.
- One question I had
when I didn't bring up
but just when and the
confirmation bias model as well
what form of confirmation bias?
So we did it is this sort of the ignoring
information or is this
sort of being biased
in how you interpret information?
And am I right in thinking
that you're thinking,
brother what does it really matter?
Sort of either one is gonna
have some sort of effect
which has information that
doesn't fit my prior expectations
is gonna be more likely to
be played less of a big role
in how I changed my beliefs.
So maybe it's because I look
at it, but then I just count it
in some way, that's the bias in relation.
Maybe because I don't even look at it
and we can gloss over
some of the psychological
differences there and use this
model to explore either one.
Is that how you would
think of what I'm gonna do?
- Exactly, and I'm suggesting
I mean there's actually
there's another whole framework
for modeling confirmation
bias in the, yeah the mathematical
social sciences literature.
Where you model confirmation bias
as just having extreme priors.
And you get to then make confirmation bias
a purely rational thing your
capital are all rational within
a particular decision theoretic framework.
But it doesn't involve
ignoring or reinterpreting
or changing what data you're updating on.
It involves just updating more slowly.
So we're avoiding we're
suggesting that that doesn't
actually have although
it's well entrenched
as a modeling procedure.
It doesn't seem to me that
it adequately captures
the salient feature of confirmation bias
of several different types of,
we think is operative in this case
or it's maybe inoperative in this case.
- Can I, so like when you,
that seems right to me,
yeah it seems like it's not
just a matter of extreme priors.
What do you yes...
What's the criteria by which we're then
objecting to that as a model?
Because like someone could then object
as well to the sort of
ignoring data model,
which they have that's a
tendency people maybe have,
but they also have the tendency to look
at surprising things.
And so like how do we,
whenever we have a psychological tendency
it's gonna be because humans are complex
and attractor was going be 18
others that we could layer on
which may have may reverse the effect.
(both murmuring loudly)
- I mean so I think
there's two things to say.
One, is that the extent to
which that's true, right?
That there are other
equally plausible things
that I could add on that
would reverse the effect.
I would see that as just
a failure of stability
of the model and would make
me much less confidence
in drawing any inferences at all
from a model with that character.
But of course like we have we're
in a particular epistemic
position where we know somethings
there's some things we worry about.
Some things we don't know about yet,
we're trying to figure out how it works
and we're just part way through.
And so these models haven't
been fully evaluated
for stability on one way in
which you might try to rule out
a particular mechanism as a plausible one
you have to worry about,
is by showing that it's not stable
under small perturbations that
you think would make it more realistic.
- Right so the, I think I have a looming,
like ah we don't want to
end up with the models
untractable so we can't
keep on adding things.
Is this strategy more piecemeals
well we have some model which captures
a model of confirmation bias.
And then there's the question
well if you add like a,
an interest in a surprise does that
like counteract the effect.
And when we can sort of
we don't wanna try to model
the 18 psychological mechanisms
that could interact with this,
but we can take one and then
try adding the second one
and try adding the third one piecemeal,
and see whether they
so it's sort of like a
pick from your slew of reasonable
psychological mechanisms
and try to pick as few as you can.
- Yes although the way that
I think about is a little bit
different just because,
so I think of these models
as being tools for reasoning.
In the sense that you
have some vague ideas
about how things are gonna
relate to one another
how these sort of says or
social psychological phenomena
that, that you've observed,
or that you read about it
in the literature how they work,
and how you think they're
gonna work in a social setting.
And now you try to extract from them
some of the basic features
that you think are
the salient ones and you
set up a model in which
you just have those sort
of simple components
and you see what happens.
And then you get these results
now you're trying to figure
out what the results mean
why these outcomes happen,
like what's going on
you start playing with the model
and and playing with the
model you start getting
a sense of how what's in the model
interventions are changing things.
Which sort of gives you a sense of
how the model is actually working.
Which then leads you to start thinking
about how to interpret
the results generally
and how they bear on like the expectations
you had originally.
Are you surprised by some things,
not surprised by some things
just when you're actually
in the first place.
And often in that process,
you start thinking,
oh, I see in this model
we're getting this result
for that reason.
But that's not really what's
going on in the real world
that looks like it might be an artifact.
We should try to adjust
the model in a way that
removes that artificial element
and see if we get the
same kinds of results.
To what extent is the
thing that I now am worried
was driving the results,
but isn't really particularly realistic.
Like actually the thing that's
driving them the result.
And so it's not just come
up with a new mechanism
and add that to the model.
It's more like in reasoning
about how the model works.
You learn something about the
phenomenon in the first place
but also something about the model.
- It's convincing to me.
- What's that?
- I said that seems convincing to me.
- Yeah I mean it's a dialectic process
that I think is, I mean
I think it's pretty
common in science, but.
- I certainly had that
where like, I was expecting
an effect in a model like Bush
one way where it turned out
there was another effect
I didn't see coming
which pushed the other
way and then there's Alex.
So that's why I can't (murmuring) yeah so.
- And I mean, I can give an example
from a paper that came
on I was working on with
one of our PhD students right now,
where they discovered
that confirmation bias
implemented in one way, in a network
of systemology model
and improved outcomes.
And they were like, oh
what's happening here?
And it seemed to turn out
that what it was doing
was slowing down learning
in a way that kept
transient diversity in some
network structures long enough
for enough data to accumulate.
Which in retrospect
makes perfect sense to me
the way these models often worked
was not at all as I understand
it, what they expected.
And now you have this sort of
a judgment call on some level
like to what extent do we
think that is really a possible
role that confirmation bias
can play in real world cases?
And what would it take to establish that?
And to what extent we think
that this is just an artifact
of the modeling framework
- Didn't Miriam and Solomon
wrote a paper arguing that
I don't know if I've read the paper,
but something like that like I can deny
like that seems like a cool.
I don't think it was
a computational paper,
but it was like-
- That confirmation bias.
- That I had this effect that's sort of-
(James whispering)
an example of plate tectonics
I don't remember the detail anyway.
- I don't think I know the paper.
I think there's a book by
two cognitive scientists
that I think advances some
version of this thesis.
You probably know it.
- I think in a museum, I've heard that.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah I've got that.
I've a lot of of questions
that we're seeing
it's forever, but we can.
So that's probably for another time.
- They're really questions
for Caitlin, not for me.
- Yeah okay.
- So there were a few other
things here that I wanted to
to come back to here.
So the rational model stuff, this is a
I think so, I think that understanding
how polarization can arise
under strong rationality assumptions
is really interesting and important.
I'm not...
I mean all of the models
that we're looking at
are sort of low rationality models,
bounded rationality models or models where
a strategy is adopted that's
not even doubtedly rational.
It's intended to,
we produce some apparently
occurring phenomenon
not one where we have some
background justification
for why that kind of
behavior would be rational.
But one that seems to be happening I mean,
this is how I think
about the trust dynamics.
When you we don't...
Scientists don't read papers by people
who they think do dumb stuff.
So what's with that I mean isn't it's
just part of the literature?
I mean well, I mean, yeah
we can give you a waste of your time
but maybe you just think that
it's not going to be fruitful
for other reasons that.
You know even if you had
all the time in the world,
that you wouldn't actually get
reliable information from it.
I think that in cases like that
and you probably can give a pretty nice,
full rational case where you sort of
you have a theory of what
the other person is doing
and you have some priors about
how useful it's going to be.
And maybe you do a cost benefit analysis
or maybe it's that,
you think that this is
all noise, no signal.
But we aren't trying to
to model all of that.
And I think on some level
it doesn't matter for us,
whether or not there's a
story that you can tell
in all cases that gives rise
to that kind of outcome.
Yeah so I guess this is sort
of a question back through you,
which is it sounded to me
like if one were gonna adopt option two
you would need to believe that,
rationality wasn't just
a normative framework
but it was a fully descriptive framework
for human cognition
and social interaction.
Like, are you committed to that?
- I certainly don't wanna be,
but I mean I guess
there's different projects
you'd be trying to answer one would be,
there's a pure social
this multiple question,
which is like, does do
rational agents polarize?
And like you can be in
that question independent
of what you think about folks like us.
Now that's relevant in so far as like
sometimes people will
write arguments saying,
well look people are polarized
and that must mean they're being idiots.
And so like in so far as
it blocks that inference
then it's a interesting
normal the fact that
though it ends so far then
as the mechanisms by which
insofar as then we move we
both of us have that normative
thing and then can connect it
to various psychological theories.
And so and then maybe the
case can be made for us.
- Is how possibly claiming
the first sense that
I discussed right there, yeah.
- [Kevin] That is how
possibly(indistinct) yeah-
- Right before we shift
team we have an interesting
kind of a relevant
question from the audience
Sanjeev Kumar asks, do you
think we might be better off
focusing on the contextual features?
In other words, the nature of constraints,
giving rise to polarization?
Many of the preference based approaches
to learn about aggregate
level features are based
on intentional agents.
And so they are making a
I guess the point is that
they're making a strong
assumption about freewill.
Do you think confirmation bias emanates
from a high risk preference?
And that's an interesting take, yeah.
Either of you want to take a
shot at it, go for it, yeah.
- There are some,
(indistinct) are you under some forms of
I don't really understand
these papers off the top
of my head but that argue
some form of ambiguity,
aversion, uncertainty about what your,
how accurate your beliefs
are gonna be something
you can be averse to and
can lead to something
like confirmation bias.
So that's something like a
high high-risk preference
I don't, and some of at
least as far as I understand
some of those models it's,
it's a strange sort of ambiguity aversion
and so far as if you're
like have confidence 50 50
in a question then you,
there is no ambiguity
you know exactly how
inaccurate you're gonna be.
Whereas if you're a confidence
80% you're not sure whether
(indistinct) the distance
between your degree
of confidence and the truth is 0.5,
whereas or whatever
your distance metric is.
it's the same dog beside a zero or one.
Whereas in when your 0.8
it it's potentially different.
So you're unsure exactly what
your distance is gonna be
and layer on some level of,
I think risk aversion/ambiguity aversion
and you get surprisingly you get something
some sort of confirmation bias.
Now that's another case where I think
like Jim said about the
extreme priors case thing
that's an interesting theoretical results.
Doesn't seem super
plausible to me that that's
what's driving confirmation bias.
I don't think people, I
think people if anything
prefer to have extreme opinions rather
than opinions around 0.5 (indistinct)
So there's some subtleties there.
I don't know if Jim was thing, okay.
- I mean the main thing,
I'm sort of focusing on the
first part of the question
of focusing on contextual features
like the nature of constraints
giving rise to depolarization.
And it does seem to me that, that
so this is something that
came up a bit yesterday
with a question that Priya
asked whether or not we can
we ever ever sense that, that,
one model of polarization
might be better suited
to some particular case than others.
And I think that, that the
answer is probably yes.
And I think that the right
way of thinking about that is
that you're focusing on
contextual features and sort of
your some background
understanding you have
of how the particular issue is dealt with
in the particular social group
that you're talking about,
what the nature of the issue is,
what kind of evidence is available,
how information seems to spread.
And so I think that in particular cases
we can say a bit more
and sometimes even quite a lot more.
On the other hand, that
only helps a little bit
for some of the bigger picture kinds
of questions that we're interested in.
And so as a purely practical matter
of what you're imagining,
it's something like, well,
suppose you have the view that
at least some of the
polarization that we've seen
in the US and the UK say,
in the last 20 years has been
driven by new technology.
- Oh, you mean the, so the, okay
polarization not you're
not talking, you're talking
about the response to say
new technologies, right?
- So, but what I'm saying it's like
like if some combination of like the rise
of certain kinds of cable
news channels followed
by the rise of social media
has led to a feedback loop
that has driven polarization.
You might even say something like, well,
part of the problem here is
intentional decisions made
by social media companies to
drive engagement on their site.
So there's a, they're incentivized
to maximize time spent
and shares and things
like that because that
maximizes ad revenue.
And so you want to promote
highly emotional content
or promote content that is surprising
in a certain way or
content that's, you know
you may not even have a
theory of why you just
you have an algorithm that
identifies what content
seems to get the most
interactions and the most shares
and you promote that more broadly.
You might think, okay, well
that's actually driving polarization.
Now you say, what kind of
policy interventions, either
as a social media company or
as an oversight organization
or as a government you want to introduce?
At that level of description,
the contextual factors don't matter
because you aren't
worried about polarization
about vaccines or polarization about COVID
or polarization about election results.
You're worried about
polarization writ large
and it looks like in general any
or all of these
considerations could matter.
- Yeah.
And I guess, so he has
a follow-up question.
If we use the framework of
the approach avoid dilemma,
then confirmation bias can
come from avoidance behavior.
Yeah, fair point.
Yeah, I see that.
But you know, I had a more
kind of a provocative question
for you both.
I mean, underlying all of these ways
of thinking about polarization
isn't that the assumption that people
are interested in the truth?
- Yeah.
- They did be possible.
I mean, as a question
that is separate from
if we don't conflate that
with rationality, rational
behavior and so on.
I mean, what if we were
to lose that premise that
that sort of prior, maybe there are people
who are not interested in the truth value.
I know that takes us
nowhere in terms of modeling
but I was just curious, right.
It seems like, for
example, you often watch
this is my, one of my pet examples.
And so you know, you watch it,
I suppose you go to YouTube
and you say, I want to
watch the latest space X
satellite launch that I missed.
You go and look at it, right.
And then other things
that you might like, right
along there is a flat earth society link
that shows up, right.
And that as you just mentioned, Jim
and both of you address
these questions, like
social media, et cetera, leverage.
So it's like other related
things that you might
these are not assessed for truth value
or anything it's just shows up there.
And so now this flatter
society yours, their, whatever
their link has the same serials
in the rank choice search method
that Google is using, right
so that it's asking you.
So and how can somebody,
I mean, unless you are not
interested in the truth
and you're just looking for
an excuse to join some kind
of affinity group of people who, you know
people who like the color
red, people who believe
in the flat or whatever,
I put all of those kinds
I mean is that kind of, how
do we take that into account?
And that, is there any
way we could model that
or is that through our hands and give up?
- I mean, well Jim has stuff to say too.
I feel like, I mean, I feel
like it's a great question
and somewhat complicated one.
I think for it seemed,
it's definitely right
that people have many motivations
like govern what they see
and how they think that
aren't just figure things out
that you're on YouTube prop,
you're on YouTube you're probably not like
in your peak epistemic
and peak inquiry mode,
you're probably like
at best sort of having
a informative pastime, whatever.
So that's totally right.
I think it, as far as my read
on the psychological literature
on motivated reasoning
and motivated cognition
and related phenomenon is
that it is rarely so simple
as that people don't care
at all about the truth.
It's rather that they have
other things and then they
somehow those can push
them to use information
that can convince them of
various things in certain ways.
So, I'm thinking of stuff
I think you mentioned in the last session
some work by Dan Kahan as well
which shows that often
more polarize people
on a given topic are the ones that
on various measures are
more cognitively reflective
or more scientifically literate.
They know more about an issue
and they are able then to rebut problems
with (indistinct) about standard.
Because I think as far as I
know the same thing is true
in general of conspiracy
theorists that like anti-vaxxer is
or truth is about nine 11
or whatever are people who
in general know a lot more
than I do about this sort
of vaccine distribution
and production processes
and about what happened on,
days leading up to September
11th and that sort of thing.
And so in general, I think
certainly there's room to point
to non truthy motivations.
And that, I think that's like
the motivation for the need,
but Jim's models where
people can go to conform
that sort of thing or other.
I think those actually
might fit quite well
with sort of contrary search.
But I think it's too easy we
make it too easy on ourselves
as the model as if we just
think that can be thought
of as this person doesn't
have any concerns with truth
rather it's sort of it filtered
in all sorts of subtle.
- I mean, there's a sense in which this is
using a certain kind of
decision theoretic framework
to describe what people do,
but there's a sense in which
so for instance in the
model that uses conformity
that Kevin just mentioned,
they care about some truth.
They care about what
payoff they're going to get
and their pay off it's a combination
of pay off due to their
true or false beliefs,
their true or false beliefs about,
she's also about to go
give a talk so I think-
- Oh great.
- There's true or your false beliefs
about the proposition at
hand which is gonna have some
lead to some ashes and have some payoff,
but also there drove false
beliefs about conformity
because I got to pay
off from that as well.
And in some sense the way that
I tend to think about it is
like people are motivated
by something and they care
about whether or not the
actions that they take
bring about the outcomes that they want.
Now they may not be able to articulate
what outcomes they want.
The outcomes that they
want may not match up
in the way that others
is outside observers
would think of as sort of
characterizing the outcomes space.
But there's some feedback from the world
to any decision that you make.
And if you're just
totally wrong about what
that feedback is going to be,
I guess some people are unhappy,
but I mean you're not...
it's not gonna work out for you.
- Right.
No, but I mean, I like the yeah, I like...
I kind of understand, and
I get what you're saying
for the view that it is not
like super useful to think
about people being
polarized as some people
not being invested in the truth at all.
Because it really, I mean,
they're invested in the truth
but modular X, Y, Z, and
I think that's, yeah.
Now I get it yeah.
So I think that it would not be possible
to classify people's psychological takes
as invested in truth,
not invested in truth.
That's not an access that's useful, yeah.
So I think are there any other
questions from anyone else?
So if not, I mean, I think we
have a little bit more time.
We have a lot of 10 15 minutes
and we can continue
along the sort of points.
So Kevin, I wanted to hear from you
what your assessment is of the sort of
agent modeling approaches.
Because I mean Jim kind
of told us what he thinks
about their limits that advantages,
and what is your kind of take
of that kind of approach?
Or do both of you then the
open question to both of you
is have you thought about what other kinds
of mathematical sort of
quantitative approach
might be useful framework?
- I can say, I mean I think
I'm broadly in agreement
with a lot of the things Jim says are very
for many purposes that is sort of
how plausibly research
program he was describing
seems interesting and useful
and sometimes surprising
and maybe more importantly and tractable.
I actually come at this from
a slightly different thing.
I come from a more analytic,
formal epistemology side
of things, but we're using it's much more
less computational based,
much more proof-based
much more detailed models
of detailed rational models
of individual agents.
It's closer to the
microeconomic equivalent
if this is macroeconomics
up to microeconomics.
And so coming from that
background the way I found
these sort of computational models useful
in a slightly different way
or from a slightly different
angle perhaps than Jim does it.
Now that I think about it pro
informs most of my questions
which is using the models to
lift up those other techniques.
So there are sometimes you have
a model of how individual
and individual reasons
or how they update on evidence or whatnot,
but it's very quickly
it becomes attractive when
you think of how they're gonna
do it over a long period of
time or meet with many other
interacting agents not something
you can write down proofs
very easily about at least
except in very special cases.
And so the one very useful
thing for computational models
that often you're just simulate it
and see what happens when
an agent do acts in this way
would you specify and argued
make sense or whatever
or at least actively describes
the psychology and the sort
of scenario, see how that
will evolve over time.
And this is the thing I mentioned
earlier with Jim where I
analytically had some humps
that would go one way.
And in fact, once you simulate,
it goes a different way
'cause there are multiple
competing factors.
So that's one way in which
I feel like it can be used.
So not I wouldn't want to
say certainly the only way
but as a way of lifting
up either psychological
or other motivated sort of
microeconomic style models
of individual reasoning and
seeing what the effects are
when iterated or writ
large 'cause that's, I mean
that's the way I combine some different
mathematical techniques
with computational ones.
(indistinct) I also have
a list of other questions
I can pepper Jim with if we wanna.
- I mean so I'm hearing for
you this question in part,
in the context of how to think
about agent-based modeling
in comparison with
various simulation methods
in other areas of science.
And so even in the kind of
example that Kevin just discussed
there are a few different
things you might be
thinking of doing with
a simulation, right?
So one is you just have
some computationally
intractable problem.
And so you solve it numerically
and that's the sort of thing
that we sometimes think of as
a simulation in some areas of science.
You might also think about yeah,
okay so we can just leave it at that.
There are sort of
general slew of different
computational techniques
that you could bring
to bear on problems.
And there are sort of
intermediate cases where
it's not totally clear whether
you should think of something
as an agent based model or not.
The way I usually think about
agent based models is that
you're I mean you're thinking of them as
a collection of individuals
parameterized in some way,
that have some dynamical properties.
Arguably cellular automata
are agent based models
on that definition, but that's not people
how usually people think about them.
And so okay so just what is it that makes
a nature-based model really
an agent based model.
And I think you can very quickly come up
with counterexamples to
virtually any definition
you could could give even though we have
a pretty good general
idea about how they work.
But I mean, look think about like,
particle mesh type models in cosmology.
There's a sense in which
we're talking about particles,
but it's also the case that
we are representing particles
we're representing regions of face space
and that they behave
kind of like particles
from one point of view.
And so there's some
sense in which this is a,
just a numerical method
for solving certain
complex differential equations,
which themselves have an interpretation
as governing small bodies
acting in the collectives but-
- I mean there are proxies
with convenient properties
for numerical manipulation
basically, right.
Because I wondered whether,
I mean I guess one of
my question is whether,
is there a just an
information flow approach
that could be used?
Could we just make maps
of information flow
and intersections between
those maps collisions
between those bits of
information or whatever.
I'm just trying to see if there are
if one want to model, what
is it the transmission
of that causes that ends
in polarization and so on.
I'm just freewheeling here
trying to see what kind of
approach might be an interesting new way.
Because one of the goals
of our longer-term project
is really to try sort
of try and understand
what are the ways in which we
can depict complex processes,
from which we are able
to pull out causation.
Infer causation from correlations
and deeper correlations.
How do we kind of, how do we
characterize complex systems
in terms of the causal
relations between entities
that are part of the modeling scheme?
So I was just curious,
like in a matter of way,
is there a sort of another other
are there other approaches
we could consider?
- Yeah I mean Jim might know more on that.
I feel like I sort of
sometimes think of the,
some of the agent-based models
that Jim was describing.
As doing something like
giving a map of information
throw it, how does information flow
flows from people saying and doing things.
And so when we think of people
are connected in certain ways
via maybe networks of trust or
communication or interaction.
And then we can model that
as social sort of like the
the two models Jim was using
the first two (indistinct)
and conforming-
- Perhaps kind of models.
Right, the network graphs,
kinds of models of a-
- [Kevin] Yeah.
- If you did being a
kind of a continuum here
maybe driven by computational
tractability considerations
but where you though from
very complicated networks
and very simple rules for
how information propagates
on the network, to very simple network.
Maybe just a single agent
or a small handful of agents
and complex, psychologically
realistic models
of how those agents process information.
Which are themselves often
network models, right.
You can have like a and
network representing
the single agents, right.
But that you're sort of
there are modeling
frameworks that use very very
simple dynamics for how
information propagates.
So for instance, epidemiological
models are often used
in social epistemology.
Less by philosophers but
often by social psychologists
to study the flow of information.
And what happens is basically you have
either some very complicated network
or just random polarized interactions
and there's some probability
of some transmission.
You can think of that as
modeling information flow
through a network or
through some population.
- Got it.
Kevin we do have a few more minutes
so if you have any last points
that you would want to discuss
and bring up with Jim, please go ahead.
- Yeah I mean, there was one I mean,
well a small questions that I came with
I feared I would people with.
But that was one question
I had that related
to what Jim was saying at
the end of his talk and maybe
somewhat less related to
some of this discussion but
insofar as he was worried about this,
the initial worry for the
three different models
explaining polarization
was why are they competing?
They're giving different explanations
and so does that mean they're
in competition in some sense.
One question I had when
thinking through the model,
the first was basically to what extent
we can see them all as
arising from one root cause,
which is trust in some sense.
So like, we're thinking
about the conformity model
in particular, like in many contexts.
Like what does the link
represent in a context where
or what a model these
people is doing A or B
and they're learning from
some people and not others.
Well, if we're thinking
about a political reason
like it better not just
be lines of communication
because communication is cheap.
Everyone can commute
with everyone nowadays.
It's gotta be something
more robust than one
natural thing is that the lines of trust
they're the people that you listen to.
And so like in this little model,
the reason why this there's
no link between these two
is not because this person can't see
what this guy is shouting,
it's just that this person
doesn't trust that person.
On that interpretation then it looks like
the conformity network
models might have very
similar motivation and
very similar driving force
underlying them that to
the trust dynamic one.
And likewise, you might even
think with confirmation bias
why is it that you people
tend to disregard information
that they find a surprising,
well big reasons that they don't trust it?
Like when Breitbart comes
out with a big news story
about like what the Clintons were doing
in mid nineties or whatever,
I think it's pretty questionable.
I'm not probably not gonna listen to that
because that and the reason
I don't trust them as before.
And so, I mean, maybe
that's a unification without
the potential that a unification
and name without unification substance.
I mean, trust can have
very different meanings
in different contexts.
But I was wondering if
there is some deeper
unity that could be had
within these class of models
as in some sense trust drives.
- Yeah I mean, I think that
there are a lot of interesting
things that one could say
or think about more here.
One remark is just,
there's an interpretation
of the trust model that we've presented.
Where's the dynamical network model.
And really what's going
on is we have either
everyone is connected to everyone,
but the strength of
connection moderates over time
as a function of distance and belief.
Or you could even think
of it being a kind of
a literal distance people
are arranged on some
grid and move in belief space
over time and listen to others
based on their actual
distance in that space.
- Do you see like the scary
New York Times or the thing
that like is mapping
polarization within cities.
Like within cities you see
there's like massive red and blue section.
So on, since it came
out earlier this year,
it's fast (indistinct).
So like literally space
sometimes correlating, right.
- But I mean, there's also, there's the
like what's the causal direction.
- Oh yeah, yeah it was up there, right?
- Yeah I mean, I think so...
I think that there's something to that.
Nonetheless I also think that
you don't need to think
about the connections
in the conformity model
as representing trust.
You can interpret them as for instance
literal geographic and inaccessibility.
Or there's been a lot of
theorizing about what happens
on the internet, some of which
has been debunked actually,
but where you have this
idea of filter bubbles.
Where there's literally,
you see different content
and you it's very difficult to gain access
to the other kind of content.
And that leads to an interpretation
of the conformity model where
it really is that you're not
seeing everything that other
people are putting out.
Yeah, you're right that
it's not that you can't
in principle overcome that,
but it's sort of the first thought of not
what you're exposed to.
And so I think it's interesting
that even if you don't have
I mean there may still
be some underlying level
of which trust is coming in.
Like, why is this the social
network that you've built?
Or why is this, why has your
what they call news diet
or media diet shaped
in the way that it is,
it has to do on some
other level with trust.
But it turns out that
just differential exposure
is sufficient even if
it's not trust-based.
So I think that that's
an interesting upshot,
even if there's some other
underlying explanation
that makes this really more about trust
and it's presented in the first instance.
- Yeah it sounds like one could diffuse
even if one could diffuse the worry
that these models are
incompatible by saying,
well they all stem from the same thing.
It's maybe not wise to,
because the general point about
even if they did have different.
'Cause even if we certainly interpret this
as geographic location or
whatever then they could be
the point that they can be sufficient,
not competing in interacting
causes would be right.
That's compelling yeah.
- We seem to be at a
moment of a natural pause.
Let me quickly check if
there are any other questions
have come up in the chat.
I don't see anything.
So I guess it's time to say
thank you to both of you
for a really nice, useful
clarifying and a fun discussion.
Wouldn't it be wonderful
if we had a solution
to a thing, understand polarization?
I think polarization
is probably inevitable
to some degree or the other.
I guess it's part of human,
psychological, emotional
intellectual diversity that
we may have to live with,
but the kind of extreme
levels of polarization
have been so detrimental
to society and culture.
And in particular, the
polarization around science
and around facts and reason
have been deeply disturbing
in the last couple of decades.
So I wanna thank you both Kevin and Jim
for this really wonderful afternoon.
It's been a real privilege to
listen to both of you discuss.
And it's a treat that we were
thankfully able to replicate
in this virtual situation.
And in many ways I think
while the pandemic has
really thrown a number
on many of our approaches to
interacting and convening,
one of the good things has been the reach
and the possibility to get people
without leaving a carbon footprint.
Well, not as big a carbon
footprint to convene and converse.
So thank you both to, and bye
to Irvine and in Pittsburgh
and have a wonderful
weekend, a long weekend.
Thanks everyone I want
to thank the audience
for attending and participating
in this fabulous event.
And I want to thank Ty
for helping organize this
and to guide for helping with all the AB.
so bye everyone have a lovely-
- [Kevin] Thank you Priya.
- Thanks Kevin.
Thank you.